[Music]
in Oh business news submitted by Jamali
and sand dunes Oh an Instagram star with
2.6 million followers couldn't sell 36
Amish I saw this XI 36 in such an
arbitrary number like he's old
thirty-five and he's like oh man but I
couldn't felt 36 it's a girl is that is
that BOTS followers then maybe they
ordered three dozen shirts no how come
they're not going no that's crazy what
could be also it kind of it could be
that like because there's a lot of like
bikini people like Instagram models like
they're really like appealing to guys so
like 98% of their audiences male and
then if they try to sell like female
teen I think she's like a fashion one
yeah but you know those Instagram girls
right the majority that follows on guys
no no the bikini ones no guys not the
TNA ones like all those like like skinny
scantily clad when I'm talking about
like the Playboy ones
it was giant yeah they are like you if
you want look at the comments it's all
like I want to [ __ ] you baby but
majority of their followers are not guys
like what is it box is actually women
well the ones that are commenting are
guys yeah because they're not dumb
enough to follow those accounts I'm
saying this like because when we work
with brands they always say the same
thing those women have the highest women
followers ever like it's weird because
guys comment but they don't follow them
so it's always without failed those
women for some reason it's because women
follow them the most I don't know if
it's because they want to be more like
them or they think that's what guys want
girls I'm following house guys are more
secret with that [ __ ] because they'll
just like but they'll comment on [ __ ]
but they won't meet I think you're
you're overestimating the majority of
guys I'm not see this assumption though
I'm saying like from every brand that
I've worked with they always gave us the
analytics of the female followers that
work with them and the female followers
have a main feel of us are not like
bodybuilder girls cuz those girls are no
I'm talking about ass girls
fat ass chicks the ones that are
half-naked models is [ __ ] like that they
actually have a bigger female following
the male fault alright so the story here
it's about Ari she's 18 years old she
has 2.6 million followers on Instagram
that's a lot but it doesn't mean [ __ ] is
what it look or she looks like and then
so she posted this photo
what's her brand like well how did she
sound louder this is her merch
yeah she's like I thought she's more
like fashion style like that kind of
yeah so this is her merge it's era and
then she posted this caption well that's
the longest use to caption ever whoa
there's longer she's pretty much saying
how she spent all this money she worked
so hard in creating her merch line and
how she flew people and to do like the
styling and the photo shoot and all this
stuff and she's saying that the the
company she's working with to produce
although her merch she has to have sold
at least 36 pieces and an order for them
to continue to sell the rest of the line
so now she did this announcement of
saying like you know I couldn't even
sell 36 pieces so everyone who did buy
anything you're gonna get a refund home
continue to work with this company I had
to sell 36 pieces I couldn't even do
that and she was all saying like how she
said care packages to people and like
she's promoted for other people but
these people can promote for her and
like that's pretty much what's in this
whole caption Wow are you a bad person
are you a piece of [ __ ] maybe this pose
from the screenshot it has 35,000 788
likes also her edges are pretty good for
2.6 million that's low that's not a lot
of likes for 2.6 well interest that's
true yeah but 2.6 - no it's not yes it
is dude okay what's the last time you
guys have seen influences on Instagram
like older every day but 35,000 like Gio
gets back and exactly but that's what we
have but we have my interaction we're
gonna have two point six million three
thousand every photo but we actually
have high interaction a lot of these
people who have a million followers or
whatever they only get like 20,000
around that range look at Tim stuff -
Tim gets around the same license we do
but he has way more falls in us there's
a lot of people who blew up bigger but
they don't have our connection with our
fans like we do comparing it to a very
different small group look at a lot of
people who have four million of 30,000
20,000 30,000 20,000 they all have cream
it's still like
like within a range of like three to
like two to three percent this is like
way below that no I'm saying
four million five look at any of them
right now our batch in Logan Paul in
that category yeah I don't think they're
the same cuz they get like a hundred
thousand I think like more like
influencers as in insta models yeah
fashion gurus are like themes that are
more like a dime a dozen
I've haven't seen them have like hundred
thousand exact likes and and stuff like
that unless you know you're talking
about musicians or people like real
security talk about when I say that us
we're all different tons of influencers
because we have a personal connection
with our fan base these people blew up
from having clothes looking nice that's
about I haven't looked at that Instagram
because I only look at people that I
follow a lot of naked women and that's
about it so I just well all I do is I
look and I go scroll pass
yeah Oh 37,000 got it yeah yeah because
I think YouTube people's like I don't
like Brett men or whatever a lot there
the engagement is just wait yeah and
looking uh for example even a major
clothing brands like they'll have a
million four thousand likes
five thousand likes and I think it's
because it becomes a repetitive thing
that a lot of people see and you're not
liking them for the personality post for
us people our best our lives so they
like it because they feel this sort of
connection before a clothing girl that
makes sense what major organizations
start trying to be relatable it gets
kind of cranky I follow the Marine Corps
Instagram yeah and then they have this
one where it was a tank and it had a
big-ass flash coming on the front and
then the caption was true chorus I'm
like you are America's military just
write some dope [ __ ] about the Abrams
tank or something like why do you want
to write your car isn't like all my god
gonna be relatable
you know nothing Jon Snow
did you have a [ __ ] military guide a
horse your dumb [ __ ] no I would like
that post yeah so this is her brand era
and so people are pointing out as well
that this is ugly this is totally not
what her page is about
I wanted to know okay that's what I
wanted to know what her branding was yes
so they're saying a lot of people are
saying like why would your followers buy
something that you wouldn't even wear so
so it's off her brand yeah that's what I
was trying to get at like I'm still
surprised 19:36 have a connection at all
because if they love the person like
look at Ariana Grande's [ __ ] right
Ariana
yeah Ariana's [ __ ] up yeah but people
were like why I still like her and I
want to support and say that I'm like
part of this group you know what would
you call that like is it more fashion or
lifestyle her per her Instagram like I
feel like there's some influencers that
are just like like more like in-between
travel and fashion it kind of blue yeah
so it's like this is my life this is
what I eat this is and it's like oh look
at her life it's dope she does think so
cute or whatever right and there's some
that's like just fashion we're the back
like the background doesn't even matter
they're just wearing different clothes
all the time and then there's TNA like
tits and ass she seems more like
lifestyle I feel like it's the they must
be like fake likes or some [ __ ] because
that's so unreal or fake followers maybe
in 36 shirts I I think a random person
can sell 36 shirts that's out you know
to meet like a hundred words gosh could
sell merch what if this is a genius plan
for her to get attention so that's what
some people well before I get there
another thing that people are pointing
out is the fact that she didn't even
promote her own things it was the
product announcement this is one promo
post and then this is her product
failing post and her feet also she only
had three policies yeah or two before
she failed even in high
they're saying like you didn't even
promote your own stuff either so why
would people even buy it
that's a one of these conspiracy
theories that she is lying either lying
about its empathy exactly lying about
the fact that she stole 36 shirts or
she's trying to get sympathy and profit
off of this whole scandal in the future
because now the product failed post is
deleted so people are like saying is
this a marketing stunt if I couldn't
sell 36 shirts
I'd die yeah I would especially with a
Down million follow literally jump off a
cliff with a t-shirt that says I
couldn't sell it like what the well I'd
buy that shirt yes you would you come
back and actually people will probably
buy more shirts after your dad he's like
let's [ __ ] 36 shirts no like what
about your friend Ian on a street corner
but install that made sure it sounds
like a sympathy pool like yeah yeah it's
that much were these shirts maybe they
were like $200 oh yeah that's a good
point they don't mention the price yeah
oh I never thought of it yeah cuz it was
like $35 okay
she's trying to be like separating $100
for that 35 40 bucks I'll buy sure
people are also pointing out the
engagement stuff so they're saying like
you know if you really had anywhere near
2.6 million followers like there's
pretty like it's a no-brainer that at
least 36 people in that follower account
would support you just statistically it
doesn't make any sense yeah like that
doesn't make any sense at all to grant
the influencer bubble is bursting
because of this no it's not before like
there's so many things that are like
obviously wrong it's older people that
don't understand the influencer world
that are like it's bursting see they're
getting influenced by the [ __ ]
old-school [ __ ] what does it use that
they want yeah I like how they're saying
like the the what's it called the social
media thing is bursting as they're
writing the article on a social media
app still happening and talking about it
who are you talking about you jackass I
think the behind the scenes is coming
out much faster though like if you think
about how long traditional media has
kept I guess like a facade
right where people didn't know how a lot
of [ __ ] work behind the scenes like this
the influencer [ __ ] is coming out to the
surface real fast because this hasn't
been around that long and people are
realizing like Oh a lot of these people
are fake as [ __ ] mm-hmm just because
like poor fat girls have better buying
power of the men a hundred percent like
in in every [ __ ] yeah all you
[ __ ] over here to get crazy
brand deals your guys's like interests
point in that direction yeah you mother
you're like just go in that direction
no that's affirm here you actually knew
mom you got the harley-davidson brand I
mean thank you I benefited from that um
I don't even know why yeah I didn't get
the revolve one but I got the Harley do
I know that's well under well I didn't
know that I'm just saying I'm not girly
enough this type of girl I am I get
hardly she got a chosen brand deal from
Dollar Shave Club surprised if you did
women's razors never work on me actually
I've seen some of the girls that follow
up they they'd get Dollar Shave Club and
it's like hey skip the pink tax because
there's this theory that like they
charge or women's product you have more
from female products because it's like
is prettier packaging yeah but then
that's been disproven by a lot of things
I use I use Muriel's she had an extra
pink razor I think I like you way better
than my guy won yes they put smoothie
[ __ ] on that feminine [ __ ] fur on
your face
that's not the reason the main reason is
because it's so much like I use a guy
razor how do I choose a guy razor too
heavy dude the girls are so much like so
many blades the girls want to have a lot
of blades to see this is why you get
male brand deals all right do you
understand yeah one time I had a try
Steve's razor because I left mine at
home we were traveling and it was so
much cooler like it feels like I'm like
working with the tool oh really
my mom uses a straight blade heavy Jess
uses a straight blade it is sharpen it
on a leather strap oh dude what was she
shaving just even relays maybe I don't
know what she uses this for I used to
get into like her the bathroom stuff and
cut stuff with it it's really sharp yeah
[Music]